die skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge der show an diesem
sonntag mit dabei ist über max jolla und
ich darf euch sagen dass wir diese woche
richtig richtig richtig krass viele
einsendungen gesund hat richtig gute
qualität ultra viel verrückter scheiße
ist diese woche mit dabei es waren sogar
so viele dass ich ein paar einsendungen
in den nächste woche verschieben musste
weil die wir zu viele gute einstellung
hatten für diese woche
danke dafür richtig gut von euch und
deswegen gibt es für jeden einzelnen der
in dieser woche auch ein hacker
einsendet guten hacker einsendet in
ordentlichen qualität beim neuesten
returns retweetet max an und ich lege
für jede einsendung noch eine trilliarde
dollar oben drauf oder 5 milliarden
dollar
ok 5 milliarden dollar für jeden für
diese woche können wir uns mal loslegen
gesagt wir haben viele viele viele geile
clips und ich würde sagen ich gehe jetzt
sieht dank immer neuer dritter der erste
clip heißt es hacker schon drei fleck
einmal party hashtag enyo eski vom usb
finger und wir legen
ich werde einer fliegt und somit ohne
drogba bringt doch alle hier sind
teilweise schon absolut geht darum dass
man nicht den boden berühren ja genau
wie im laden stehen muss man kein ja es
geht um das sind auf einer cd
jetzt fliegen schon 2
zwei fliegen du siehst man sieht partie
23 fliegen und bis auf bis auf die zeit
der aufnehmende zögern geschrieben du
hacker jetzt sagt der typ leute haltet
euch fest der typ der über dem boden
schwebt ja und gerade eben noch
offensichtlicher weise frei gehackt hat
in mario party der sagt jetzt opfer ich
hätte nicht wir sehen noch nicht wie er
vor seinem pc sitzt mit wassergraben ja
weiß woran es liegt ich weiß woran es
liegt ja ich glaube es lag meinte
einfach nur das ein richtig richtig
gutes mauspad hat deswegen in der luft
stehen wenn er genau hinschauen
es gibt eine oper ja da sieht man erst
ein gutes mauspad das mauspad wie schon
auf diesen aufsatz und kristalline er
hat einfach ein gutes maß beim start und
bei den anderen kann ich erkennen
könnten
zweimal ein headset sein wer dafür
braucht man die den mord der das einem
anzeigt bei leute mit verdammt gut und
gaming haben wir wieder am start das
video einfach genau an dieser stelle das
mysterium bleiben wir diese runde
gewonnen hat sollte und wir springen zur
nächsten
leute platz vier heißt hecke und whiskey
in the sky und stammt von reni 200 hd
und wir legen direkt los wir sehen hier
auch schon max ist schon angemerkt sehen
hier so selbst immer abhebungen entweder
ein text objekten dass musik opels
dornhai leitet oder interesse
cobblestone x-ray texture pack 2016
april es gibt verschaffen sohn porter
denn immer wieder auf die koppel tonnen
fallen
es geht es erwarte weißrussland geht man
du weißt ja okay da ist der dann per web
computing arbeiten an zeigt die
verborgene welt aber lustigen wie die
ganze also über die hohe arbeiten reden
während der typ einfach übertreibt
komplett das gefühl ist wirklich einfach
zu diesem zeitpunkt einfach noch runden
läuft jemand sie so man richtig traurig
da ist er wieder der kollege ist aber
über die lava gesprintet gerade ja ja ja
klar die gewinne so schnell ist hätte
ich nicht auf wir wissen ob er jetzt
alle drei in diesem test match
beklatscht und variieren baum sind
der dia jazbec grün auch diese frage am
rand deswegen kommen junge für einen
moment hätte ich gedacht dass der hacker
die noch pds durch
wie kann man den durch blöcke
durchschlagen dekker muss ja den
richtigen stuhl kaufen wo du willst du
müssen irgendwann muss muss ich mal im
wörterbuch rausbringen dem erklärt wird
welches gaming gucken welche effekte
bringt in minecraft aber das fällt das
wäre zu krass glaube ich das mögen sie
auch viel heftiger verkaufen als
minecraft von luca und deswegen schauen
wir einfach noch mal den link lippe an
unternehmer darunter und jetzt schlägt
latics what the [ __ ] zweimal und er
rennt um sein leben war der start noch
durchs eis gekühlt werden aber der
hacker geht tatsächlich drauf und leute
ich habe ja gesagt dass diese woche
richtig rund geht und ich glaube sie
geht richtig rund
also dass er da einfach so
durchgeschlagen hat richtig richtig
krass irgendwie dass das geht wusste ich
gar nicht
die einsendung stammt von niemand
geringerem als diejenige der ist das ein
gesendet hat heißt einfach mal bei auf
jeden fall eine taskleiste noch drin
also wir sehen dass es geliefert
find ich wie ich model manager die und
jetzt acht mal drauf laut richtlinie gar
nicht mehr zurück
er trifft die partikel fliegen aber der
andere kriegt keinen schaden mehr
einfach dann kann auch auf einmal kann
er nicht mehr getroffen werden und das
game ist flüssiggas ist keine lex ist
du siehst dass ein gegner läuft sich
sehr stimmt ja auch mal hier trifft
schwert trier einmal zweimal dreimal
wird trifft dann nicht mehr und die
partikel fliegen also er trifft ihn auf
jeden fall
er trifft ihn und die die haut auf die
hit box als er muss ich noch treffen
asx chip
jetzt geht nichts mehr
an dieser stelle möchten wir nur einmal
anmerken dass wir in keinster art und
weise marihuana konsumieren und es wird
zum zutaten braucht wie beendet okay
leute der nächste platz platz 2 heißt
delfin hacker und kann zu kurz da intel
weiß dass sein delfin ecke das 2 stammt
von iks allen pad müde
okay er erst mal wieder der hoch
deportiert wurde so hell war und warum
erhalten
warum erst mal einfach ein kleines warum
an dieser stelle also müssen wir mit dem
gold bugs schauen wer ist bei der bilder
sehr verdächtig und der tatverdacht okay
leute motto känguru mäßig
ich bin wieder ganz gut wie alles klar
und alles klar
ach die anderen aber einfach angelegt
drin sowie den cup plätze ist schon mal
den preis gesetzt und es mit 2016
vergeben aber der wird auf jeden fall
zurückgenommen und anträgen ab was der
facc es macht einfach was da war das
waren richtige dürfen was wir sehen
gerade ja das stimmt ist ein ring aus
den wellen raus
das buch ist von so einem steckt täter
seien also vollkommen random aber er hat
ja nicht so eine krasse glaube ich ne
oder segler wieder irgendwas mit strange
ja ich meine wenn du in so einer
geschwindigkeit dich bewegst und so
unkontrollierte ohne clara triffst du
gar nicht verrückt machen
ja aber ich bereite das känguru vor dem
känguru modus charge mega 100 des
matches okay das ist relativ starr
williams alles klar
denn hier aber sowas violas auf 450
straight kritiker hätten leute sich
trotzdem gegensatz getötet warum macht
er das sextape alter so leute platz 1
erreicht in einer folge hacker show die
richtige spaces mit allen möglichen ex
musste die auf platz eins rein knall in
die handelsplatz heißen gegner
teamwechsel heckhoff randy um scott d
und stammt von metzger 2016
hier sieht irgendwie so aus als sollten
roten eigentlich hauen können er sieht
ein bisschen wirkt zu wissen von wörter
wie es gefühl warcraft abgesehen es gibt
von jeder farbe so noch einer übrig ja
eben eben einmal pink einmal gelb einmal
rot aber dasselbe
der rote ist da und der pinke ist der
aufnimmt alles klappt nimmt auf wenn sie
irgendwas lucky wars ja jetzt also der
rote ist in einem anderen team
wieso kann nicht hauen ja ich hätte es
auch gar nicht fitten okay ja er kann in
welcher anderen jungs zeit mit gibt kein
fachpersonal und ich will hier bauen
junge es geht ums bauen steht auch schon
einen namen ein job ist es halt
schokoladen keinen minecraft glieder
also der aufregend ist rosa und der rot
rot das heißt diesen zwei verschiedenen
teams aber können sie nicht frauen sind
allerdings dessen spectator soll ja
jetzt keine davon machen wie aber
konnten sich beide gegenseitig hauen
du hast einer perenne alles klar denkt
dran kollege geändert werde
hey was jetzt wieder nicht hauen passt
das für ein verräter
der mentor verblödet dabei staub
verbreitet
aber meist an runter gefallen er
überlebte fakt ist es ist das
gekoppelter godmode oder wie also er
konnte ihn erstens haben wir gesehen ja
dann mal kann er wird er geholt und kann
in andernach wieder hauen ja oder es war
allerdings zement dirigent gegeben hat
dass waldman aber es waren auch partikel
da kam schon von der seite und er hatte
ich auch zurückbauen alles passt schon
und jetzt kann ich wieder nicht hauen
du wirst nicht weiter leute woran kann's
liegen wenn ihr eine ahnung habt oder
irgendwer schreibe es in die kommentare
ein danke für alle einsamer diese wochen
richtig geld bald weiter so viel findet
nein danke fürs dabeisein kulisse
entscheidet hat mag es in der
beschreibung dort rein macht
machen sie mit